هذا واحد من بين مواقع عديده تابعه لوزاره
الدفاع البريطانيه هنا يتلقى المجندون
الاوكرانيون التدريبات العسكريه كثير منهم
مدنيون من دون خبرات
انهينا المرحله الاولى من التدريبات
التكتيكيه والاسعافات الاوليه واليوم
نتعلم المهارات الدفاعيه والهجوميه
انفسهم من المدفعيه المعاديه
التدريبات تحاكي واقع المعركه من متفجرات
وقنابله وتقديم اسعافات
نعلمهم المهارات العسكريه التي يحتاجونها
لتمكينهم من البقايا على قيد الحياه
والدفاع عن ارضهم تقود بريطانيا منذ الصيف
الماضي عمليه انتر فليكس لتدريب 20 الف
اوكراني وقد تم تدريب نصفي عددهم حتى الان
بمشاركه ضباط من دول حليفه تدعمه اوكرانيا
ومنها استراليا ونيوزيلندا والنرويج
نامل ان يعود المجندون الى اوكرانيا وهم
جاهزون للمهمه التي تنتظرهم وقد عززنا
قدراتهم على البقاء والنجاح
مع مرور عام على الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا كثفت بريطانيا وحلفائها تعزيز
قدراتك الدفاعيه بما فيها تدريب جنودها
على الدبابات الثقيله وهناك تعهدات لتشمل
التدريبات مشاه بحريه وطيار مقاتلات
الجزيره شمال الشرقي انجلترا